[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend kiffen für alle und
zwar völlig legal und in Shops
erhältlich darauf hatten sich ja einige
in Deutschland schon gefreut nicht nur
Konsumenten sondern insbesondere ein in
den Startlöchern stehen da
Wirtschaftszweig doch dazu wird es erst
einmal nicht kommen die geplante
Cannabis Legalisierung fällt kleine aus
und beschränkt sich zunächst auf den
privaten Bereich und auf Vereine klingt
schlicht klingt einfach lässt aber doch
extrem viele Fragen offen die ich gleich
den Bundesgesundheitsminister stellen
werde zuvor Britta Spiekermann
was an diesem Tag auffällt die Minister
Lauterbach und Özdemir scheinen du nein
bitte erst du so etwas wie ziemlich
beste Freunde aber wo ist FDP
Justizminister Buschmann noch im Urlaub
heißt es lapida und das ausgerechnet bei
dem Herzensanliegen der Ampel Lauterbach
war lange gegen die Legalisierung jetzt
will er sogar Vorreiter seinen ganz
Europa mit einem umfangreichen Fahrplan
mehr Sicherheit im Konsum Konsum eher
einschränken Schwarzmarkt zurückdrängen
bessere Jugendschutz weniger
Beimengungen weniger Drogenkriminalität
es sind geänderte Eckpunkte die die
Minister heute vorstellen brüssel hatte
im November einer ersten Fassung eine
Absage erteilt nun also das was von all
dem übrig bleibt nach den Plänen soll
der Besitz von 25 Gramm zum Eigenbedarf
sowie der Eigenanbau von drei Pflanzen
erlaubt sein in Cannabis social Clubs
kann gemeinsam angebaut und Cannabis an
Vereinsmitglieder abgegeben werden ab 18
es geht um eine kontrollierte Abgabe an
Erwachsenen das ist ganz entscheidend
und gleichzeitig in maximalen Schutz
unserer Kinder und unsere Jugendlichen
die Kriminellen Dealer die werden sich
nicht freuen über den heutigen Tag der
Schwarzmarkt wird sich wenn man so will
schwarz ärgern das ist auch gut so zur
Wahrheit gehört dazu die Ampel bleibt
weit hinter ihrem Versprechen zurück im
Koalitionsvertrag steht wir führen die
kontrollierte Abgabe von Cannabis an
Erwachsener zu genusszwecken in
lizenzierten Geschäften ein jetzt soll
es nur regionale Modellprojekte geben
aber selbst das ist in Bayern zu viel
ich glaube dass dieser Weg ein Irrweg
und ein falscher Weg ist in der Frage
Legalisierung von Cannabis Verharmlosung
einer Droge es wird dem Kinder- und
Jugendschutz Schaden es wird den
Schwarzmarkt auch nicht austrocknen nach
Alkohol und nikotines Cannabis das am
häufigsten konsumierte Suchtmittel die
Polizei sieht sich schon seit langem
auch verlorenem Posten und glaubt jetzt
dass ich wirklich etwas ändern könnte
und wenn beispielsweise 25 Gramm
Cannabis straffrei blieben und das im
Gesetz zu festgelegt wird und die
Polizei dann auch grundsätzlich von der
strafverfolgungspflicht aufgenommen ist
das gehört natürlich dazu dann würde das
in diesem Bereich eine Entlastung der
Sicherheitsbehörden bedeuten für
Jugendliche die mit Cannabis erwischt
werden soll es verbindliche
Präventionsprogramme geben aber was ist
für den Arzt der beste Jugendschutz
wir stellen uns den natürlich so vor
dass Kinder und Jugendliche möglichst
eben nicht an Cannabisprodukte kommen da
Cannabis für Jugendliche und wir sehen
Konsumenten schon mit zwölf Jahren
erhebliche Gefahren birgt das kann zu
Psychosen führen die ein Leben lang
bestehen bleiben zurück zu den Ministern
Lauterbach und Özdemir die Ampel wollte
viel im Koalitionsvertrag jetzt kommt
die Liberalisierung von Cannabis in
kleinen Schritten die Erkenntnis des
Tages es ist ziemlich verzwickt bei
demonstrativer Harmonie
und wir Zwecken jetzt noch ein bisschen
weiter und zwar beim Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach schön und Abend nach
Berlin guten Abend es wird also
deutschlandweit keine lizenzierten
Fachgeschäfte sondern Vereine und
Modellprojekte geben ohne staatlich
kontrollierte Lieferkette werden sie
aber doch den Schwarzmarkt und das ist
ja eins ihrer Ziele nicht trockenlegen
also das Projekt kommt in zwei Phasen
zunächst einmal diese Cannabis Vereine
wenn man so will das sind nicht
profitorientierte Vereine für den
Eigenanbau wo bis zu 500 Mitglieder
darin sind das wird sich sehr schnell
entwickeln und das wird den Eigenbedarf
weitestgehend abdecken bei gleichzeitig
besserem Jugendschutz die Abgabe durch
lizenzierte Geschäfte das konnten wir
bei der EU nicht so auf den ersten also
anlaufen durchsetzen da hat es
vertrauliche Gespräche gegeben das wird
dann in Modellprojekten wird das also
entwickelt aber der größte Schritt ist
doch der erste Schritt dass man hier
also qualitätsgesicherte wahre bekommen
kann ohne Drogenkriminalität ohne Dealer
ohne also Beimengungen ohne Toxizität
das ist doch ein riesiger Schritt noch
vorne ja gut aber dann bleiben wir mal
beim Verein der darf also nicht
gewinnorientiert sein fragt sich wer das
dann eigentlich macht und ich frage mich
das was sie gerade angesprochen hat
kontrolliert dann die Polizei oder das
Gesundheitsamt anbauqualität Abgabemenge
oder wie soll das praktisch ablaufen die
Länder kontrollieren das die haben dafür
dann entsprechende Freiheiten das auch
umzusetzen aber diese Clubs müssen
natürlich bestimmten Kriterien genügen
da steht zum Beispiel dann
festgeschrieben dass jedes Clubmitglied
maximal 25 Gramm pro Tag bekommen kann
maximal 50 Gramm im Monat bei you bei
Menschen zwischen 18 und 21 30 kann
Abgabe an Kinder Jugendliche unter 18
ist strengstens verboten es darf nur
eine wahre sein ohne Beimengungen es
gibt eine Reihe von Regeln und der
Schwarzmarkt angesagt der wird dann
zurückgedrängt denn der ist da nicht
mehr notwendig für denjenigen der sich
versorgen will okay und weil sie jetzt
mit der Verbotspolitik keine Erfolge
hatten geben Sie Cannabis mehr oder
weniger frei warum aber gibt es kein
umfassend durchdachtes Konzept zur
Prävention also wie wollen Sie die
Einstellung verhindern Drogen sind okay
zunächst einmal das hat ja eine riesige
Wirkung wenn das so kommt wie wir hier
glauben dass der Schwarzmarkt einfach
nicht mehr die Bedeutung hat weil ich
hier also quasi die Ware
qualitätsgesichert ohne Kriminalität und
ohne Beimengungen bekommen kann dann ist
auch nicht mehr der Druck auf die
Jugendlichen und Kinder da die sind ja
jetzt die Opfer die drogenkriminellen
Fragen doch überhaupt nicht nach dem
Alter derjenigen die da konsumieren die
Mengen beide wollen jemand so schnell
wie möglich abhängig machen das ist doch
alles schrecklich und schlecht und wenn
das zurückgedrängt wird dann sind das
wichtige Schritte dazu werden wir für
Kinder und Jugendliche schon beim
Erstkonsum wenn da jemand also
tatsächlich aufhört werden wir
verbindliche Präventionsprogramme
anbieten somit die Kinder werden besser
geschützt und die Erwachsenen auch in
diesem Zusammenhang ist auch die
Freigabe ab 18 ja schon auch fragwürdig
sie wissen dass wahrscheinlich besser
als ich dass das Hirn bis zum Alter von
25 ja noch quasi umgebaut wird Cannabis
kann da Störungen Psychosen und
ähnliches hervorrufen oder gar auch
verstärken ist das nicht fahrlässig von
Ihnen wissen sie im Moment findet das ja
alles statt und zwar mit toxischen
Konzentrationen zum Teil viel schlechter
kann es ja gar nicht sein als jetzt wir
haben mehr Konsum wir haben Beimengungen
wir haben keine Kontrolle wir haben
Kriminalität wir haben eigentlich im
Moment eine gescheiterte Drogenpolitik
wenn jetzt ab 18 der Konsum erlaubt ist
aber das sind dann geringere Mengen die
abgegeben werden und das ist nicht
toxisch beigemenkt sind das schon mal
Schritte nach vorne wir werden natürlich
massiv aufklären auch über diese Schäden
die sie gerade beschrieben haben ich
sehe das auch als ärztlicher Perspektive
aber es ist ja nicht so als wenn wir das
Problem schaffen sondern wir haben ja
ein viel größeres Problem und die
gescheiterte Drogenpolitik die geht
nicht weg wenn wir den Kopf in den Sand
stecken also Aufklärung ist gut das weiß
ich nicht ob es dann den ein oder
anderen vom Kiffen abhält eine Frage
noch das Verkehrsrecht wer positiv auf
THC getestet wird aktuell muss dann mit
einer Geldstrafe oder aber auch dem
Führerscheinentzug rechnen bei
Legalisierung kommen dann eigentlich
Grenzwerte wie beim Alkohol haben Sie
das schon mitgedacht das wird derzeit
mit Verkehrsminister Wissing genau
besprochen wir haben dabei eine ganz
klare Regel also in diese Eckpunkte
geschrieben und das Gesetz kommt ja Ende
April Anfang Mai hier werden sich die
Regeln ausschließlich nach der
Verkehrssicherheit richten es wird keine
anderen Aspekte geben die da irgendeine
Rolle spielen sagt Karl Lauterbach sind
wir gespannt die Gesetzgebung das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren kann ja noch
einiges ändern der Gesetzentwurf soll
dann Ende des Monats kommen vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit ich danke Ihnen
und wir haben noch ein bisschen mehr zum
Thema in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute können Sie Hanfpflanzen interaktiv
unter die Lupe nehmen und in unserer 3D
Story lernen wie die Cannabinoide im
Körper wirken
jetzt blicken wir ins Ausland Joe
bidensreise nach Irland ist eine Reise
auf den Spuren der eigenen
Familiengeschichte aber auch auf denen
gelungener Diplomatie die Amerikaner
hatten vor 25 Jahren
maßgeblichen Anteil am
Karfreitagsabkommen wir haben die Woche
schon darüber berichtet mit dem die
Gewaltspirale pro britischer und pro
irischer Paramilitärs ja beendet wurde
zwei Gründe also die bei seiner
geteilten Reise nach Nordirland und in
die Republik Irland immer wieder zu
sehen waren Hilke Petersen hatte heute
für uns alles im Blick
man muss das irische Wetter wirklich
mögen es regnete auch heute auf den
US-Präsidenten herab der aber brennt für
die Insel seiner Vorfahren ist gekommen
um deren Heimatort zu besuchen und sich
stark zu machen für den Frieden in
Nordirland vor 25 Jahren beendete das
Karfreitagsabkommen den Bürgerkrieg
zwischen katholisch irischer und pro
britisch protestantischer Bevölkerung
[Applaus]
wurde hinterließ einen leeren Stuhl am
Esstisch ein Loch im Herzen das nie
gefüllt wurde bei denen die jemanden
verloren hatten Frieden war
unausweichlich wir können das niemals
vergessen
beim Tee mit dem britischen premiersunak
hatten sich beide neu vergewissert die
angloamerikanische Beziehung lebt
doch wirklich fühlen lässt sich das erst
hier draußen an der irischen Küste bei
Schloss Karling Ford
wie ist es hier zu sein
wunderbar als käme ich nach Haus
das Schloss Gemäuer angeblich das letzte
was beiden Ururgroßvater sah als er 1849
in See stach Richtung Amerika als irisch
ständig würden sich 30 Millionen
Amerikaner beschreiben zu Hause sind sie
eine macht auch als Wähler
[Musik]
natürlich gibt es angestammte
Verbindungen hier und das ist die
persönliche Note dieses Präsidenten
Besuchs in der Republik Irland und er
freut sich weitere Orte der Vorfahren zu
besuchen und möglicherweise entfernte
Verwandte zu treffen aber die beiden
Story in Irland gibt es so ähnlich
vielfach in Amerika
die tiefe Verbindung wirkt wie eine alte
Abmachung auch heute wieder in den
politischen Gesprächen über das
instabile nordirische Parlament seit
einem Jahr schon Tag des nicht mehr wer
sich zusammenrauft dem stellt der
Präsident neue US-Investitionen Aussicht
wie Schutz und Hilfe
die Familie zählt auch wenn irische
Auswanderung ein Kapitel ist aus der
alten Welt
ihre beiden ist
ausgesprochen sentimental wenn es um
seine irischen Verbindung geht und das
amerikanisch irische aber er ist 80
Jahre alt und denkt darüber nach wie es
war als er aufwuchs Irland aber ist
längst kein Land der Amerika Auswanderer
mehr
America in Irland aber mögen sie die
Geschichte noch immer und beiden hofft
dass sie auch im nächsten US-Wahlkampf
wieder funktioniert
und unser Studioleiter aus Washington
begleitet Joe Biden bei dieser Reise und
damit erstmal guten Abend Elmar diese
Reise warum ist die jenseits von seinen
irischen Wurzeln eigentlich so wichtig
für ihn
ja sie spielt natürlich schon eine Rolle
für den amerikanischen Wahlkampf bei dem
wir davon ausgehen dass er andere der
hat ja am Wochenende angedeutet und er
kommt hierher weil er gerne Bündnisse
schmiedet das hat er in Belfast heute
gemacht indem er daran erinnert wie
wichtig es ist das windsor-abkommen
umzusetzen also sich irgendwie zusammen
zu raufen und eine Lösung zu finden hat
das ohne den erhobenen Zeigefinger getan
und dann ist er eben hier in der
Republik Irland unterwegs gewesen hat
mit den Menschen auf Augenhöhe
gesprochen also diese Mischung aus
Problemlöser und ich sag mal
mitfühlender Zuhörer das ist etwas was
im amerikanischen Wahlkampf auch
eigentlich sehr gut angekommen ist beim
letzten Mal und es werden hier Bilder
erschaffen die dabei natürlich nützlich
sein könnte spannend ist ja auch beides
nach John F Kennedy erster zweite
katholische Präsident spielt das da
jetzt eine Rolle
ja es spielt auch eine Rolle auch ein
Stück weit für den Wahlkampf es gibt 70
Millionen Katholiken in den USA und sind
längst nicht alle irgendwie der Meinung
dass die Demokraten die richtige Politik
machen viele sind deutlich konservativer
aber wenn Joe Biden hier unterwegs ist
und beispielsweise am nockschrank beten
wird am Freitag Nachmittag oder wenn er
in der Kathedrale von Merkel ebenfalls
am Freitag auftritt wenn er dort sich
die Geschichten anhört die sich um diese
Kathedrale Ranken und um den heiligen
dann ist das echt und dann ist das
authentisch denn selbst seine Kritiker
sagen eben es ist ein Gläubiger
Präsident für den spielt Religion eine
große Rolle und wir erinnern uns an
seinen Amtsvorgänger für den Tat
Religion eigentlich nicht so viel bzw
spielt es keine so große Rolle er gilt
nicht als gläubiger Mensch Donald Trump
er hat ja die Bibel wir erinnern uns
auch einmal falsch rum in die Höhe
gehalten wenn es dem politisch nützte
also unterm Strich Joe beiden sammelt
hier zwar Bilder aber es ist eben echt
und authentisch und das will er als
Signal mit in die Heimat senden sagt
Wissen der den US-Präsidenten bei seiner
Reise begleitet vielen herzlichen Dank
ja beiden also in Irland die deutsche
Außenministerin in China und Gundula
weitere Minister sind ja auch auf Reisen
gemeinsam besuchen Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius und entwicklungsministerin
Schulze Niger und Mali im Westen der
Krisen geschüttelten Sahelzone in Afrika
beide betonten Deutschland werde sein
Engagement für diese eine der ärmsten
Regionen der Welt fortsetzen in
niedersonne so Pistorius der
militärische Stützpunkt für
Lufttransporte ausgebaut werden und
Svenja Schulze bekräftigte Deutschland
werde weiterhin Landwirtschaft und
Schulbildung fördern um Terroristen den
Nährboden zu entziehen und den Menschen
dort eine Perspektive zu geben
Italien hat angesichts hohe
Flüchtlingszahlen erneut die EU zum
Handeln aufgefordert erst gestern hatte
die italienische Regierung landesweit
den Notstand ausgerufen auch um mehr
Gelder zu Bewältigung der Migration
bereitstellen zu können zunächst sondern
mit 5 Millionen Euro neue
Aufnahmezentren im Süden des Landes
gebaut werden der Notstand gilt zunächst
für sechs Monate seit Jahresbeginn
wurden in Italien bereits mehr als
31.000 geflüchtete registriert
in der Ukraine löst ein Internet-Video
Wut und Entsetzen aus es zeigt
möglicherweise die Enthauptung eines
ukrainischen Kriegsgefangenen Präsident
selensky macht russische Soldaten dafür
verantwortlich und fordert Reaktionen
UN-Generalsekretär gutärisch äußerte
sich bereits entsetzt es handele sich um
einen weiteren schweren Verstoß gegen
das Völkerrecht auch kremmelsprecher
Pascow sprach von entsetzlichen Bildern
die aber auf Echtheit überprüft werden
müssten
die Bundesregierung hat sich besorgt
über den Gesundheitszustand des in
Russland Inhaftierten kremelkritikers
naval nie geäußert und erneut dessen
Freilassung gefordert nawalnis Anwalt
erklärte der 46-Jährige leide an einer
unbekannten Krankheit die niemand
behandeln und habe noch einmal stark
abgenommen es sei nicht auszuschließen
das naval nie derzeit wieder unter
verschärften Bedingungen in
Isolationshaft dort gezielt krank
gemacht werden
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
lehnt eine Gebühr für das Aufsuchen von
Notaufnahmen in Kliniken ab einen
entsprechenden Vorschlag hat
kassenärztechef Gassen gemacht um die
überfüllten Notaufnahmen zu entlasten
wer nicht zuvor eine Leitstelle Anrufe
solle eine Gebühr entrichten es sei auf
Dauer nicht durchführbar dass sich jeder
aufgrund eigener Einschätzung zum
Notfall erkläre und damit die
Bereitschaftsdienste in Anspruch nehme
haben sie das mitbekommen vor wenigen
Tagen sorgte dieses Bild hier für
richtig Alarm Ex-Präsident Donald Trump
in Handschellen seine Fans waren außer
sich einen anderen Aufreger hat dieses
Bild hier ausgelöst der Papst in einer
hippen Daunenjacke allein weder Trump
wurde festgenommen noch hat das
Oberhaupt der katholischen Kirche diese
Jacke getragen die gibt es nicht einmal
die Bilder sind Fake Produkte eines
künstlichen bildgenerators grund genug
für uns mal genauer hinzuschauen was ist
jetzt schon möglich und wohin geht die
Reise Sven Regen
diese biologische Zeitreise hat eine
kostenlose ki-software gerechnet
trainiert mit Modellen die dem System
sagen was ein Auge ist was eine Nase
sprich wie ein Mensch aufgebaut ist es
bleibt der Fantasie des Nutzers
überlassen wie das berechnete Bild der
erzeugte Clip aussieht der KI sind keine
Grenzen programmiert eine KI hat erstmal
grundsätzlich natürlich keine Ethik und
dadurch dass sie keine Ethik hat kann
ich natürlich beliebigen Dinge
miteinander kombinieren sagen wir eben
Bilder von sehr jungen Kindern mit
erotischen Darstellung das generiert mir
die KI dann auf Knopfdruck dass diese
bildgeneratoren längst genau dafür
eingesetzt werden zeigt ein Blick in die
Liste der ebenfalls kostenlosen
Trainingsmodelle frei verfügbare Bilder
die der KI als Grundlage für neue
Kreationen dienen daraus entsteht zum
Beispiel dieser Clip ein Junge dessen
Kleidung verschwindet und seine
Genitalien samt Reizwäsche freilegt
natürlich wird das eine enorme
Herausforderung diesem
entwicklungs-tempo hinterher zu kommen
es wird europäische Regulierung geben
wir glauben man muss jetzt sofort über
die Vorzüge aber auch über die
problematischen Effekte von solchen
Technologien nachdenken um da ganz
schnell tatsächlich auch ein Bewusstsein
zu schaffen den längst sind die
Stilblüten wie diese die zeigen wohin so
manche Entwicklung geht gehängte
Fantasie Menschen Gesichter und Köpfe
gegen unliebsame Verwandte oder Kollegen
zu tauschen jederzeit möglich ich glaube
nicht dass man durch diese Art der
Vorgaben Prinzi
Piell ja man kann ihn einschränken aber
es wird immer Wege durch neue Proms
durch neue Arten der Variation der
Suchanfrage dann geben dann dann doch
problematische Inhalte zu produzieren
für technische Beschränkungen ist es
längst zu spät einige bildgeneratoren
sind Open Source angelegt also frei
verfügbar und so offen für jede
Weiterentwicklung aber eben auch jede
Art von Nutzung so fühlt sich das Netz
mit gefälschten Bildern echter Personen
Wladimir Putin mit einer Friedenstaube
vor einem Panzer der Papst im Netz
merkel und Obama für die
Aufsichtsbehörden ein völlig neues Feld
es geht natürlich schnell das ist eine
wahnsinnig schnelle Technik die sich
wahnsinnig schnell auf weiterentwickeln
wird aber wir sind doch besser geworden
das System der Aufsicht das System der
Regelsetzung ist besser geworden und
deswegen glaube ich wir können mithalten
und wir können jetzt auch noch
mitgestalten dass diese ja eigentlich
sehr interessanten und spannenden
Techniken auch im Sinne der Gesellschaft
eingesetzt werden und nicht nur im Sinne
von wenigen Unternehmen
denn schließlich hat die neue IT-Technik
sinnvoll eingesetzt viele gute und auch
ästhetische Seiten ein französischer
Künstler etwa hat diese Zeit reisen
durch 100 Jahre Mode erdacht erstellt
hat den Film auch hier sein ki-programm
schon ziemlich interessant so wir sind
echt und kein Fake und machen jetzt
weiter mit Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft kundula ein weltweit geringes
Wirtschaftswachstum hohe Inflation und
ein Verschuldungsgrad der wegen der
Pandemie in vielen Staaten wieder zulegt
das sind nur einige der
Herausforderungen mit denen sich
Internationaler Währungsfonds und
Weltbank auf ihrer Frühjahrstagung
befassen Sina meine dazu Krieg und
Klimawandel was kann was muss aus sich
der Finanzmärkte in Washington
entschieden werden in Washington wird
wohl entschieden werden dass die
internationalen Finanzmärkte grüner
werden sollen dafür müssen Weltbank und
internationaler währungsvorwirksamer
Anreize schaffen die Klimakrise lässt
sich nämlich nur bewältigen wenn Staaten
und Finanzmärkte wirksam
zusammenarbeiten nach Schätzungen der
Vereinten Nationen sind bis zum Jahr
2050 weltweit Klima Investitionen von
125 Billionen US-Dollar notwendig nur so
lassen sich die Erderwärmung auf 1,5
Grad begrenzen heißt es weltweit sollen
somit Öl Gas und Kohle durch saubere
Energien ersetzt werden die Finanzmärkte
haben die finanziellen Mittel ihn fehlt
bislang aber der besagte Anreiz
tatsächlich in die grüne Wände zu
investieren doch der Weg geht auch hier
zu lange nicht mehr in einer grünen
Wirtschaft vorbei die EWF Prognose für
Deutschland ein Minus beim
Bruttoinlandsprodukt von 0,1% der
Finanzminister ist alarmiert
wir brauchen ein wie ich es mal zum
Jahreswechsel genannt habe ein
wachstums-pakets denn die deutsche
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit hat offensichtlich
gelitten unsere Produktivität ist nicht
da wo sie sein sollte wir haben auf der
anderen Seite aber auch große Potenziale
und Chancen die wir freisetzen können
und wollen
deutschland solle aufholen was jahrelang
möglicherweise vernachlässigt wurde
steigenden Zinsen hohe Inflation
Klimakrise perspektivisch gesehen wird
wohl nur das Unternehmen Investoren
finden dass ich nachhaltig und
klimaneutral aufstellt
vielen Dank nach Frankfurt
der umstrittene Einstieg des
chinesischen Staatskonzerns kosko bei
einem Containerterminal des Hamburger
Hafens ist doch wieder fraglich der
Terminal toller Ort wird inzwischen als
kritische Infrastruktur eingestuft das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium prüft nun
die Auswirkungen die Schauspielerin
Maria Seewald ist im Alter von 92 Jahren
gestorben er ist heute bekannt wurde
bereits am vierten april in München
immer herzlich und schlagfertig feierte
die gebürtige Berlinerin in den 1980er
Jahren große Erfolge mit Rollen in
zdf-serien wie die Wichert zwar nebenan
ich heirate eine Familie oder das
Traumschiff
und wir haben noch die gewinnzahlen vom
Lotto am Mittwoch ohne Gewähr 27 28 33
34 44 Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-
was erwarten wir eigentlich von einer
politischen Jugend sie soll sich
einmischen laut sein weh tun für sich
einstehen da mögen die Meinung
vielleicht etwas auseinander gehen aber
das ist sie gibt ist doch sicher
unumstritten gut und in der DDR war das
anders Jugend Opposition wurde dort
unterdrückt verfolgt verhaftet so wie
Matthias sommerscheck heute vor 42
Jahren starb er in einem stasi-gebäude
sein Tod hat damals die oppositionellen
Gruppen in der DDR erschüttert und weil
viele dachten er wurde von der Stasi
ermordet aber so war es wohl nicht wie
sich kürzlich herausstellte chris hat
Läpple über eine Geschichte die bis
heute Spuren hinterlassen hat
Freitag 10 April 81 plötzlich hält der
die Zug 566 von Jena nach Berlin
außerplanmäßig in Jüterbog Matthias
domask auf dem Weg zu einer
Geburtstagsfeier wird gemeinsam mit
einem Freund verhaftet zwei Tage später
ist er tot
Mensch wir damals eigentlich wie es
mehrere viele gab er war belesen er war
auch sensibel er war empathisch und das
sind alles Eigenschaften er hätte er
wäre ein sehr wertvolles Mitglied dieser
Gesellschaft geworden
Matthias domaschke ein sanfter Rebell
Teil der Jena jungsszene lange Haare
Motorradfahren westliches Songs hören
eine Freundschaften und Zusammenhalt den
eigenen Weg suchen Mats wird früh Vater
er raucht Caro mag Police Cover den
Songs wohnt das ist ungewöhnlich in
einer WG
hier in Bremen drei ist das Haus leider
in dem er gewohnt hat abgerissen worden
es war hier rechts ein ziemlicher
Bruchbude aber es waren Freiraum ein
Stück Freiheit für ihn wer anders ist
bekommt in der DDR rasch Probleme Max
kann Ungerechtigkeit nicht ertragen er
unterschreibt den Biermann Protest die
Stars sie recht sich Matthias wird vom
Abi ausgeschlossen Job als Heizer und
gilt als feindlich negativ
man hat da wo keine Feinde waren
Jugendliche zu Feinden erklärt und zu
Feinden gemacht und das teilweise
wirklich mit Fehleinschätzungen und
Wahnvorstellungen was für Gefahren von
diesen Jugendlichen ausgehen könnten
Domaschk wird mit seinem Freund in den
Stasi Knast Gera verfrachtet dort wird
er 13 Stunden verhört am 12 April
mittags gibt Mats auf er will nicht ein
unterschreibt eine
Verpflichtungserklärung als im die
Alternative 10 Jahre Haft
das letzte ja man muss sagen
selbstbestimmte handeln war es dann dass
er gesagt hat nein das mache ich nicht
ihr kriegt mich nicht
ich mache mich nicht gemein mit euch
nicht mit eurem System
und dann hat er in einem unbeobachteten
Moment was auch ein Fehler war
sein Hemd genommen und war tot und wurde
tot aufgefunden für wenn sie es geht
nach drei Jahren Recherche fest es war
Suizid tot durch Erhängen so steht es
auch auf dem Totenschein tragisch wenige
Minuten vor seiner Entlassung in diesem
Jahr soll es in Jena eine Gedenktafel
geben
es müsste
vielleicht darauf stehen und bedauern
das Bedauern auch von beteiligten also
ich wäre auch einer der dann im
flugstraßen niederlegen Matthias starb
mit 23 Jahren wie er in den Tod
getrieben wurde erzählt das
beeindruckende Buch Jena Paradies
und das Paradies ist in Jena übrigens
ein Park mit einem gleichnamigen Bahnhof
so und jetzt am besten einfach
dranbleiben und das auslandjournal
Gucken unter anderem mit einem Blick auf
die republikanische Basis und vor allen
Dingen auch wie trump-fans trotz oder
gerade wegen der Anklage mobil machen
und um 0:45 Uhr meldet sich Hanna
Zimmermann mit unserem heute schon mal
Updates wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir schauen auf
den März und das ist die regenstatistik
die wir hier sehen in blau
gekennzeichnet wo es mehr als normal
geregnet hat ja und in rot wo es zu
wenig geregnet hat und hier sehen wir in
Spanien war es viel zu wenig aber auch
auf der alten Südseite in Norditalien in
der Poebene viel zu wenig Regen der dort
gefallen ist bei uns regnet es derzeit
recht ergiebig und auch morgen kommt
neuer Regen auf in Form von Schauern
hier kommt Kaltluft reingezogen und in
dieser Kaltluft bilden sich dann Schauer
und auch Richtung Alpen da ist einiges
los mit Schneefällen und auch am alten
Rand z.B in der Nacht ganz im Süden also
Schnee hier regnet es auch mal länger
ansonsten Regen und Schauer und Gewitter
die ziehen hier nach Nordosten hin ab
und dann wird vorübergehen trockenarbeit
tiefsten Temperaturen von 0 Grad im
hessischen Bergland ganz im Osten bei 7
Grad deutlich milder und morgen gibt es
erstmal viel Sonne nach Westen hin und
auch in den östlichen Landesteilen in
der Südhälfte ist es aber dicht bewölkt
und hier gibt es dann Schauer und
Gewitter und ja zum Nachmittag auch
Schauer dann in den westlichen
landeszahlen bei Temperaturen bis 14
Grad ganz im Westen Deutschlands und
sechs Grad an den Alpen die nächsten
Tage bleiben wechselhaft vor allem der
Osthälfte dann am Freitag an den alten
Schneefälle ganz im Westen aber viel
Sonnenschein 7 bis 15 Grad ja und am
Wochenende weiterhin Regen und Schnee an
den Alpen ein schöner Abend